canopy groupe et sa filiale tweed ont
fait renaître smiths falls une petite
municipalité devenue moribonde après le
départ de son principal moteur
économique la chocolaterie feuchy
bonjour bienvenue lâchait tweed celui
qui nous accueille et c'est adam
greenblatt ancien candidat du parti
marijuana et militant pro cannabis de
longue date il nous présente le tout
nouveau musée de tweed une initiative
visant à réhabiliter le cannabis mais
tweed c'est surtout l'une des plus
importantes usines de production de
cannabis du canada pourquoi est-ce qu'il
faut des contaminés par ce qu'il faut il
faut assurer à chaque étape la salubrité
des plans c'est le chambre pour les
plantes mères on a plusieurs arrêtés ici
les employés qui sont en train de
prendre les coutures et les boutures
vont devenir des petits plants qui vont
alimenter les chambres de floraison on
vient de voir les plantes mères on prend
les boutures des plantes mères et puis
on fait des clans avec donc cette
lentille s'ils sont en train de former
des gas in et après ça ces quelques
semaines en phase de croissance et de 8
à 10 semaines
raison après ça on récolte lusine de
smiths falls emploie 1000 personnes ces
derniers jours les travailleurs
redoublent d'ardeur
tandis que certains s'affairent à
remplir les bouteilles d'huile
d'autres font l'inventaire des produits
à l'abri des regards
voilà la magie menacée chez sur le
marché noir ça vaut à peu près quatre ou
cinq mille dollars puis prix ventes au
détail ça vaut dix mille dollars
et ça c'est les nouvelles boîtes qu'on
va vendre le cannabis séchées en dedans
ça c'est notre but
il permet de sécuriser pour entreposer
tout nos produits cannabis et un don
peut entreposer plus que 150 millions de
dollars de cannabis le cannabis et est
livré dans des camions très sécurisé on
peut traquer tout de la bouture jusqu'à
jusqu'au magasin ce que vous aurez
suffisamment de produits pour satisfaire
la demande éventuellement oui dans la
première phase de la légalisation on
verra des fleurs séchées de cannabis
dans plusieurs avaries t on vers des les
huiles de cannabis dont du cannabis
liquide pourrait gérer ainsi que des
gélules d'huile de cannabis et dans la
deuxième phase de la légalisation c'est
l'année prochaine on verra
l'introduction des produits comestibles
dont le chocolat qui renaîtra à smith
falls agrémenté de cannabis ici maxime
bertrand radio-canada smiths falls en
ontario